the olympic running team of freedonia
has always used zeppo's running shoes
but their manager suspects harpo's shoes
can produce better results which would
be lower times
the manager has six runners each run two
laps one lap wearing zeppos and another
lap wearing harpo's each runner flips a
coin to determine which shoes they wear
first
the manager wants to test if their times
when wearing harpo's are significantly
lower than their times when they wear
zeppos assume that all conditions for
inference were met
which of these is the most appropriate
test an alternative hypothesis so
they're just asking us about the
alternative not even the null but we can
talk about that
so pause this video and see if you can
figure it out
so before i even go into this particular
example let's just make sure we
understand the difference between a
two-sample t-test and a paired t-test
so when we're talking about either a two
sample t test or a two sample t interval
for the difference between the means
what we're doing is we're considering
two populations and you take two
independent samples from those
populations and what you're trying to do
is you get statistics off of these
samples and you're trying to estimate
the difference between the means of
these populations so it might be the
difference mu 1 minus mu 2. that's what
you're trying to figure out mu 1 minus
mu 2.
a paired situation is quite different
even though they might sound the same at
first here we're looking at just one
population
and that's exactly what's happening in
this situation right over here we're
trying to figure out what is the mean
difference between using zeppo's and
harpo's shoes so this is what we're
trying to get at
the mean difference so we could call
that mu
subzepos
zeppos
minus
harpos
and the way that we go about doing that
is we take a sample and that for each
subject in the sample we perform two
measurements one where they run with the
zeppos and one when they run with the
harpose and then for that sample you can
calculate a
mean difference between the zeppos
between the zeppos and the harpose
you're going to calculate this
difference for each member of your
sample and then you're going to take the
mean of all of those so hopefully you
notice that this is quite different and
so as you can imagine here in this
example we are dealing with a paired
t-test we aren't looking at two
independent groups or two independent
samples like you would with a two-sample
t-test
and so we are in the paired t-test and
the manager wants to test if there are
times when wearing harpo's are
significantly lower than their times
when wearing zeppos
so our null hypothesis even though that
they're not asking that our null
hypothesis would be that there's no
difference that the
mean time that the mean difference
that the mean difference between wearing
zeppos
zeppos and harpo's
and harpo's would be equal to
zero
and the alternative
hypothesis so if they were just saying
hey is there a difference then we would
say that this would not be equal to zero
in the alternative but the manager
explicitly wants to see if harpo's times
are lower than zeppo's times so what we
would want to see is if the mean
difference so the mean difference of
zeppo's
zeppos minus harpos
we're trying to find if we can see if we
can have evidence to suggest that this
is actually greater than zero and so
that would be this choice right over
there